- So welcome everybody to this
question and answer session
about the documentary, "The
Neighborhood Storyteller".
You know, I just wanna take a moment
to say why we have this
extraordinary panel today.
Because today we have Dr. Rana Dajani,
who is the founder of the
grassroot community-led program
called We Love Reading,
which Asmaa talks about
in the documentary.
We are also joined by the
protagonist in the documentary,
Asmaa Rashed,
and the filmmaker Alejandra Alcala.
I'm going to ask my colleague, Dr. Dajani,
to narrate for us the
beginning of this idea
for the documentary and introduce
both Asmaa and Alejandra,
and my role will simply be
at the moment to tell you
who I am and who Dr. Dajani is,
and why we're together here for you today.
I am Catherine Panter-Brick.
I'm Professor of Anthropology,
Health, and Global Affairs
here at Yale University.
Dr. Dajani is professor at
Hashemite University of Jordan.
She is both a scholar and
a social entrepreneur.
As a scholar,
Dr. Dajani and I have been
working over several years
on understanding better
cohorts of Syrian refugee
and Jordanian host communities
with respect to health
and social inclusion.
As a social entrepreneur,
what you need to know
about Dr. Dajani Rana
is that she's the founder
of We Love Reading,
which now has established
more than 4,000 libraries
in local communities in over 60 countries,
and the program that was imagined
and undertaken in Jordan
in the first place.
And for this work,
she's been recognized
and now with many awards.
She's been named
one of the most influential
women Arab scientists
in the world.
But for this program, We Love Reading,
she's received in particular,
the 2021 Nansen UNHCR Refugee Award,
and has been named Social
Entrepreneur Award,
given the Social
Entrepreneur Award in 2022,
which is part of the World Economic Award
that selects social entrepreneurs
and leaders around the world.
And so, she has this
international recognition
for something that she imagined
and delivered and put together
at the start local community in Jordan.
So Rana, thank you for being with us.
Asmaa and Alejandra, thank
you for being with us as well
and please introduce us.
- Yes, thank you for inviting us
and holding this film screening.
Thank you everyone for being here,
both online and in-person.
So I'm gonna introduce the film
and therefore introduce
Alejandra and Asmaa
as part of the story,
'cause I think that's more entertaining.
That's more fun.
So actually We Love Reading,
I started in 2006 reading
aloud in my neighborhood,
just as you saw Asmaa was doing.
And then, I transformed
that into a training program
to train people to do
what I did in Jordan.
Fast forward,
the Syrian unrest happened
and many Syrian refugees came to Jordan.
Jordan is a haven for
refugees from Palestine.
I'm a daughter of refugees,
from Iraq, Syria, Yemen, even Ukraine.
Today, we have refugees from Ukraine.
So I went to Zaatari camp
and I held a training there
and I trained Asmaa,
and Asmaa took the training
and as you see her life
was all transformed.
So Asmaa, you know who Asmaa is.
She's a young woman, fascinating,
amazing, full of energy
who's changing the world.
Asmaa today is in France.
She has been...
As a refugee now, moved to France.
You can guess what is
the first thing Asmaa did
as soon as she set foot in Paris.
- Eiffel tower?
- She gathered the children
and are reading aloud to them.
She immediately called me and said,
"I'm reading aloud to the kids."
So Asmaa is a powerhouse.
Now, the Big Heart Foundation,
which is a foundation
based in the Emirates,
had just started the whole
initiative of funding
and supporting refugees in the region.
And so, they contacted
the HOME Storytellers
of which Alejandra and
her father Francisco
are the directors and producers
and owners of this initiative,
of this organization.
They're really well known
for many films they do,
documentary films.
So Alejandra, who is a graphic designer,
specialized in motion
graphics and post-production,
and 3D design.
She's fascinating.
She's an amazing woman
as well, just had a baby.
So her baby was with us on
camera a little while ago.
So Alejandra and her father actually
looked around in the region,
where can they find a
real story of a woman,
who although as a refugee,
was able to make a difference in her life.
And so, they found We
Love Reading, our program,
and they contacted us.
And so, we introduced them to Asma
and they spent all the
summer of 2021 filming Asma
in Zaatari,
and the rest is history.
You saw the movie and the
movie has up till now,
19 nominations, six awards.
Of them, the Toronto Film Award,
the Mountain View Film Award,
and the Documentaries
Without Borders Award
and it's just counting.
Every day they call me up
and they say there's a new award.
So we're really, really happy with that.
And there's many reasons why,
and that's why we're gonna
have this panel discussion
with Alejandra and Asmaa
to tell us more about
their Asmaa's journey,
Alejandra's journey,
and how they both are
mirrors for each other,
Alejandra and Asmaa.
They're very close in age
and it's just fascinating
to hear them talk together.
So welcome to Asmaa and Alejandra.
I'll be translating for
Asmaa in Arabic both ways
and we want people online
to post our questions
in the Q and A.
We will follow that.
And of course,
after we have a some Q and
A with Asmaa and Alejandra,
we'll open it to the people here
so that you can ask
your questions as well.
We're excited to learn.
And by the way,
we created to go with the movie
a book, "My Mama's Magic",
which is actually Asmaa's story,
in English and in Arabic.
So you could take copies of these books
and look at the children's
book that follows Asmaa
in the eyes of her daughter.
I mean you saw her daughter in the movie.
So this children's book is
written from her daughter's voice
and her vision of how she sees her mom
and how her mother changed
and inspired her as well.
Alright, so let's begin.
Catherine, you're going to
lead us and talk about...
As somebody who's been
involved in the research,
because we've done a lot of
research among We Love Reading
to really understand how the program
has impacted Asmaa and millions of others,
and how can we learn from that
to inform other kinds of
program to do them right.
We'll talk more about that as well.
First, I think the...
We'd like to talk to
Asmaa to start with her,
the protagonist to share
with us her feelings
about being...
You know, she said in
the movie that she wanted
to become famous and a writer
and people who wanna
have pictures with her.
Well, actually she got her wish
so we'll ask her about that.
I think we'll kick off with that question
and then we'll turn to Alejandra.
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
- So Asmaa is saying that
yes, her dream came true
and this is...
Her point is that she
wants all the young girls
to believe in their dreams
and that yes dreams can come true.
All they need to do is just dream
and think big and trust themselves
and have confidence in themselves.
Alejandra over to you.
So I'd love you to share
how you first encountered We Love Reading
and then Asmaa and how
that really inspired you
to create this movie.
- Hi everyone.
Rana, great introduction
and it's so great to be here.
I really feel honored.
So actually this was like
a really unique opportunity
because when the Big Heart
Foundation approached us,
they gave us like a white paper.
They did a brief that was very open
and it gave us the freedom to be able
to find something that as filmmakers
would inspire us as well.
So that was a really
interesting opportunity
and we did a lot of research.
We found a lot of amazing
organizations out there.
But I think what rang a
bell with We Love Reading,
I think it's...
First of all, it's uniqueness
and something that was
really like beautiful
about the magic of reading.
And we thought,
"Oh, there could be like something..."
In the end, it's also art.
We thought that it could be
very interesting for the film,
and the more we got involved in reading
about what We Love Reading does,
we realized that...
And after obviously
conversations with Rana,
we realized about that reading is a bridge
for something bigger
and that was the most amazing thing.
And when Rana told us
it's a two day training,
and when we heard about Asmaa's story
and how she continued for years and years
and the life transformation
that not only brought to her
but it also brought to her community,
I mean that was probably
the moment that we said,
"Oh my God, this organization,
we have to collaborate with them."
And then, I think it was us
that suggested meeting Asmaa
because we found an article
on your website Rana.
And so, we got introduced to Asmaa
and I think from the three first seconds
of our conversation,
we fell in love with her.
Because what you see on
screen is the real Asmaa
and it's her laugh, her eyes,
the way she expresses and
her desire to not only...
It goes so much further,
her wish to make a change in the world
and that is what captivated us.
Hearing her story
and seeing that if we were
able to make this into a film
that we could share with the world,
imagine how much larger her voice could be
and how much larger her impact could be
in the lives of many,
especially women and girls
in situations like her.
- Oh, thank you.
Thank you Alejandra
for sharing how this whole thing started.
That's amazing.
Catherine, do you wanna please?
No, please continue.
I mean, I guess Asmaa has
to participate in Arabic.
So yeah, so I'll just explain.
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
So I asked Asmaa how was her reaction
when she knew that they were gonna come
and make a movie about her?
So she said,
"Well first of all,
there was a lot of phone
calls going back and forth,
introducing them to each other.
Because Alejandra,
we went through a lot of
loopholes to get them permission
to go into Zaatari with all the cameras
and all the equipment.
It was a COVID time and it was Ramadhan,
and there was limited time
and they were on a right?
And there was like,
they had to finish within
a certain period of time
but we were able to do it all.
Asmaa says that she became
very close friends with Alejandra,
which they are.
They talk all the time,
especially after this movie.
They're being called every
couple of weeks for a screaming
or to give a talk or something.
And so Asmaa said,
it also made her get to know more people
and other people, the film crew,
to think of a different
perspective of life.
Alright, we have another question.
Catherine, please.
- A question for Alejandra.
I know that people might be curious to see
what it takes to do a
documentary like this.
You have obviously, you know,
you are obviously portraying
young girls talking to you
about the aspirations and
it's very moving in that way.
They say very precious,
interesting things like,
I want my life to matter
and to be somebody.
But what is the,
like Rana just mentioned many cameras,
to have to get permission to Zaatari.
Can you tell us a little
bit about what it takes
to do a film like this from
the technical point of view
and from the organizational point of view,
not just the inspiration?
- Yes, I can of course.
I just wanted to add a little bit of,
a tiny backend of the first question.
That I will never forget
what Rana said to us
when we first spoke about
the magic that happens
after the training program.
I think that was kind of
a thing that triggered us
to make this documentary
because Asmaa was not only repeating
what she had learned
in the training course
that she did for many, many years to come,
but she had gotten to a point
where she had taken the skills
learned at We Love of Reading
and transformed them into an initiative
that came from her heart.
That's why she was trying to
gather girls that had lived
or were facing a situation
that she had lived in her past
and that had left a scar
that she needed to cure.
So I just wanted to add that part.
And then, regarding the
how we did it technically
and all the cameras,
it was a lot, a lot of work
and a lot of persistence
and a lot of patience.
On one side,
the technical part and the
logistics was very difficult
because of course it's
in a foreign language.
It's in a country that...
I mean, I had never worked there before
so you don't really know
how the bureaucracy is,
how you have to find the permits.
So we were lucky enough to be able to work
with the Royal Film Commission in Jordan,
who was really helpful
while getting the permits.
We also had Guffran from
the We Love Reading team
who was our local fixer,
which is a very good
friend of Asmaa as well.
And funny enough,
all three of us are
practically the same age.
So we all became really
good, good, good friends.
And so, it was really difficult
and I have to add another challenge
was that we were facing COVID.
So each time that we were able to finally,
it seemed that the permits
were gonna come out.
There was some sort of delay in the travel
because of COVID
and we had to re-
I forgot the...
- Schedule, reschedule.
- Yeah, like reschedule
and remake the permits.
And so, maybe some of our team members
had other prior commitments
and they couldn't work with us anymore,
so we had to find backups.
It was an ongoing process
for months and months.
Even when we arrived in Jordan,
it seemed we had all the permits
for all our team members,
and unfortunately our
director of photography
did not have a permit to enter Zaatari.
So from 20 days of filming,
it was reduced to 14 days.
And the time that we had applied for
was to have the entire day at Zaatari
and it was reduced to leaving
at three in the afternoon,
and we were followed by a policeman
who was like forcing us
to leave at 3:00 PM Sharp.
So we had to work around those challenges.
And as documentary filmmakers,
these are kind of the surprises
that you find along the way.
That's the technical part.
The story part and being
able to not make people panic
when you have thousands of cameras there,
which we didn't.
We are a very small team
and that's something that
we take care of a lot
because we know it can be intimidating.
But part of our process
and what's really important
to us and a priority
is being able to gain
the trust of the people
who are sharing their
story with us to film.
Because if you don't have trust,
you don't have anything.
And so, that was something
that for months prior
to the filmmaking itself,
Asmaa and I exchanged letters.
We exchanged phone calls.
I asked her to keep a diary.
I shared with her intimate
things about my life as well
because it's a two-way relationship.
It doesn't work one way.
I think that really helped
for when I arrived at Asma's door
to be able to not arrive
as a stranger anymore.
Asmaa I mean,
I can't even say like how
amazing she is in person,
in front of a camera, behind
the camera, at all times.
So that was amazing to see.
And with the girls,
I think the first days they
were a little bit scared
and surprised,
but I think it was very important
that they saw that Asmaa trusted us.
And if they trust Asmaa,
they trust us as well.
So that was really helpful.
And again, we're a small, small team
and so we don't wanna make
too much noise in the room.
That helps as well.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I would like to...
I think also being a woman as well
- Oh yeah.
- That makes a huge difference
for that trust and that relatedness,
and I'll never forget when you said
that you were pregnant
at that time, right?
- No, I got pregnant after editing.
- Oh well, I mean when you
were doing all the editing...
- [Alejandra] Oh yeah.
- And you said that...
You just realized that you
and Asmaa were the same age,
and you were having your first baby
and just relating those human things
that were all the same in the end, right?
That we're all humans
and we share different...
There's similar experiences,
although in different contexts
and that shared humanity is something
that we need to keep
reminding ourselves of
and which she showed in the movie.
- Yeah.
- Asmaa, I would like to ask you,
I'll ask it in English and
then I'll translate in Arabic.
I would like you to share how,
what was the process of change within you
after you took the training
and how did that inspire you
or change you to go out
and do another project,
which is the project that
was actually later on
filmed with the teenager groups,
because We Love Reading is
with the younger children.
(speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
When she started reading
aloud to the children,
this led to an openness about her.
She had just had a miscarriage
and she was feeling depressed
and not feeling well,
like very optimistic.
And so through the reading
aloud to the children,
it inspired her to have a love of life.
Psychologically, she became more positive.
She had a reason to live.
She was more present.
I'm trying to translate
verbatim to what she said.
That the relationship with the children
she was reading aloud to,
inspired her passion
and give her a sense of belonging
and that's when she
realized that some of...
Because again, she started
reading aloud in 2014.
So after a couple of years,
some of the girls who
used to come grew up.
They became 13, 14 years old.
And so, they stopped coming
because they thought this
is just for little children
and that's when she,
because of that feeling of like passion
and openness and reality...
I am here, I exist.
And of course, she went
through other things.
She became a writer
for the local magazine.
She wrote a children's book.
She became a teacher in the
local school in Zaatari.
So all these little things
inspired her that...
She identified a gap,
and the gap was that these teenager girls.
They weren't coming to the read aloud.
So she had to create something for them
and that inspired her to
start her program Let's Read
that you saw in the movie
where she started gathering
the teenager girls,
and she also designed it
to cater to the needs of these teenagers.
So she chose books that
were self-help books,
skill-based books,
so that they would learn these skills
whether they got married or not.
But it was their decision to think,
"Okay, what can I do with my life?"
She wanted subtly inspiring them to go
and get your education.
You don't have to
necessarily follow the path
that your community is
prescribing for you,
but you can think on your own.
And you saw that through the
testimonials of the teenagers,
as they were rethinking
how they see themselves in this world
and in their own community.
You have a question, Catherine?
Oh, Asmaa.
It was a hard question.
I wanted to say how impressive it was
that you gave this message
of personal change,
and I wanted to ask you
whether you also felt
that there might be or not
some intergenerational change.
So how does that affect,
maybe your own children?
Now of course you are in Paris,
they see the world and you see
the world in a different way.
But I wanted you perhaps
to comment on anything
about whether that sense of personal worth
and purpose and work
and service had changed,
not only you as an individual,
but your community around
you and the next generation?
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
- Wow.
Yeah, I wish you understood Arabic.
So Asmaa says,
of course impact was not only on her,
but on her children and her community.
This positive feeling,
how she changed,
and how she changed her
perspective affected them
but she elaborates a lot
more about going to France.
So she said when she went to France,
that her positive energy was transcendent.
It was very contagious,
and she says this is something
that she learned from reading.
Because when you read,
you learn about other people.
You become more empathetic.
So everybody was telling her,
"Don't you have a cultural
shock when you went to France?"
She said, "No, I don't."
And she says, it's all
because she reads a lot.
She's also inspired
through We Love Reading,
as we always say,
is not just to read,
to learn about others,
but also to tell your story,
to have that confidence
about telling your story.
So she tells her story and
she tells it to inspire others
and to share her positive
energy with others,
and those are her words
and that's what she does in France
and inspires all the people around her.
I'm gonna add something just
in the spirit of all this,
which to me was something that I...
It was a reflection so to speak.
You watched the documentary
and you saw it was actually Asmaa's story.
It's not the story of We Love Reading.
It's not my story who
founded We Love Reading.
It's Asma's story,
and inherent in that is a big, big lesson
is that we didn't want...
It's not the story of We Love Reading
because if it's the
story of an organization,
then we're removing the
humanity from the people
that we are trying to work together with.
This is very different.
This is unique.
This is very special,
and it was a collective
effort of all of us
to make sure that We Love
Reading was subtly there
and that it was the...
We Love Reading did not empower us.
Asmaa's empowered.
She has it in her, like every one of us.
We all had, it's how we
evolved as a species,
as humans.
It's just that we need a
little catalyst, right?
An activation energy to rekindle that fire
that for different reasons may have,
needs a little bit of rekindling.
We Love Reading just does that.
It just nurtures it, rekindles it.
But like, it's her story.
And that's why We Love Reading,
it's actually every person's
story and they own it.
It's that we call it our secret
sauce or the magic, right?
It's that that agency that
they feel I can do anything
and then they go around and do everything
and anything around them,
and Asmaa is the epitome example of this.
I think that's a lesson for,
for program development
and program interventions
and international NGOs,
as we develop programs to serve,
to support using humanitarian context
or in development.
How do we develop using that
strategy and that approach?
Because then it's sustainable.
Asmaa carries the program wherever she is.
You don't have to do anything.
It'll be taken up
because it belongs to the
person who actually did it
because Asma did it.
No one else.
And of course nobody, this is
not about money either right?
Asma did it because she
cares about her community.
She cares, she belongs,
and she talks about this
feeling of belonging
to my community, to my society,
and that's why I do it because I care.
I read a lot to the kids because I care.
I identify challenges in my community
and come up with solutions because I care.
I think that trust,
which Alejandra talked about
and Asmaa talked about,
that trust that we need to
foster between us as human beings
is so important.
Sometimes we forget it.
I think it's really, really important.
So I just wanted to touch on those
because I think that's a huge
learning lesson for all of us
and to me.
I keep reminding on myself of that.
So I think,
do you have any questions
or shall we open it to the audience?
- We should open the magic.
- Please, yes.
So who would like to ask,
start or comment or critique?
By the way, I love critique.
Because when you critique,
that's how we learn.
If everybody's gonna
say, "Oh, this is great,"
we're never gonna learn.
So please bring it on.
- [Participant] How did
Alejandra and Asmaa communicate?
- Great question.
Alejandra?
- I dunno if everybody can hear.
- Can you hear that?
Did you hear that Alejandra?
- The question is how Alejandra
and Asmaa communicated.
(Alejandra laughing)
- It's funny, you always
find ways to communicate.
If there's a need, there's a way.
And in the...
Via virtually, it's easier
because I downloaded this translator
that automatically translates my WhatsApp.
So I was talking to Arabic...
Sorry, in Arabic to
Asmaa through WhatsApp.
Funny enough, after we created the film,
now she talks English to me via WhatsApp.
So she's translating now,
and then we exchanged letters.
So she would share them in Arabic,
I would Google translate them
and then I would share mine in English.
She would Google translate.
And for the film, we actually
hired a spontaneous...
Sorry, a simultaneous translator.
So she, her name's Amani.
She did a great job, by the way.
I don't know who has that capacity
to like be hearing
something in one language
and translating it into another one.
She was in a different room
from where we were filming,
connected to the microphone
that we were using.
So she would hear Asmaa talking,
she would then translate into a recorder
that was connected into my headphones
and to the director of
photography's headphones.
And so, we were hearing the
English as she was talking,
and the recorder that
Amani was talking to.
we used afterwards for
the editing process.
So we used one channel that was in English
and then one channel that was in Arabic.
So I could use one ear for one language
and the other for the other one.
And so, that helped us make this basic cut
from all the footage that we had.
Then eventually,
with a guide of what
the story was gonna be,
how the story was gonna be told,
we then sent out to translate to a company
that actually hires refugees.
So we wanted to also be able
to continue supporting
refugee self-reliance
in that way as well.
And everything that we didn't understand,
we actually...
I think that played in our favor
because you start to
focus more on the emotions
and the human behaviors
and how someone is acting.
I think that was captured
in Asmaa's project
with the girls.
If you can, you can tell
that during the entire film.
We focused on the
expressions on the faces.
So many times when we
weren't hearing Amani,
because it was hard for her to translate
when the girls were laughing
and talking all at the same time.
We were just signaling like this girl,
this girl, this girl, her face,
and it was really emotional
and I think that played in our favor.
- Absolutely.
Another question.
Yes, please.
- [Participant] The girls in the movie,
did you select them or
are they the whole set?
- So Alejandra, can you hear that?
- [Alejandra] Yes, yes.
- Yeah, please go ahead.
- No, we didn't want to intervene
at all in the storyline.
We left Asmaa that job.
She selected, she created the project,
she designed everything.
She selected the girls.
We actually didn't know the girls
until we were actually there
when Asmaa introduced us.
She actually got the
permits from the families
to be able to have the
consent for filmmaking.
She solved anything regarding the project.
It was her, all her.
- So maybe I'll ask her
the question, right?
- [Alejandra] Yeah.
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
- So when she selected
the girls for her program,
'cause again she's not doing
this for the movie right?
This is what she's actually doing.
So the girls she selected,
she went to make sure
that they came from diverse backgrounds
so they could learn from each other
and share from each other.
So some were in school,
some were out of school,
remember this was in the
middle of COVID right?
And she also invited girls,
one of the girls was actually engaged,
almost to be married.
She wanted her to also
be part of the program
so that she could learn what
other opportunities she had,
even if she was married.
That she can still do things
and it's in her hand if she
pursues the path of reading
and education.
Education, it's not just the school right?
We can educate ourselves
in different forms
and in different ways.
And actually one of the young girls,
I don't know if...
Well you wouldn't know,
I know them all.
(indistinct) she was actually,
before this Asmaa had trained...
She came to Asmaa and asked her,
"Could you train me how to read aloud
so I can start reading
aloud to the children?"
So when she was a little bit older,
she started gathering the kids
and reading aloud to them.
And then, she became part
of Asmaa's program herself.
(Rana speaking Arabic)
Any other question?
Yes, James.
- [James] It's really a pleasure.
I guess I found myself wondering,
have you been able to interact
and hear from the fathers
and what kind of perspective they have?
I guess it's really fascinating to think
about watching the movie and
sort of being interconnected
and I guess I'm just curious about
sort of where they stand in this reality,
but thank you so much.
It's really inspiring.
- Thank you, thank you.
Well, this is for Asmaa.
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
So she's saying in terms
of her own personal story,
she was always very close to her father.
And when she was young,
she would go to his
library and read his books.
Although they were much, I mean high...
Well, above her level of reading, right?
Most of them would be more very
theory or above her stand...
Well, I don't wanna use the word standard,
but above her level...
- Understanding?
- Understanding, yes, yes.
Now, in terms of her project,
she wanted to build that
relationship between the girls,
the teenager girls and their fathers
in the community that she's part of.
Girls are closer to their mothers.
I think all over girls are
always closer to the mother.
That's just how things are.
So she wanted to close that gap
and strengthen the relationship.
So when she went,
as you saw in the movie,
she would talk to the
father about her project,
explaining what it's all about,
to gain his trust and
understanding of what it's about.
She would encourage the
girls to go back home
and talk about the program
with their fathers, right?
So they would share and create a dialogue,
an exchange between the
father and the daughters
so to strengthen that relationship.
Maybe...
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
- Yeah, okay.
So Asmaa,
she follows up and talks about how...
I followed up with a question
about what was the feedback
from the fathers, right?
To follow up on your question.
She said for the fathers,
it was difficult at first to agree
for the girls to go outside their home
and participate in activities.
And she said,
this is understandable because
they're coming out of a war
and that has its own trauma
of being protective about your family,
protective about your children.
But eventually, they
would comply and change.
She said opposite the mothers,
they were more compliant
and they would say,
"Yes, take them and teach them,
but you have to make sure that
we convinced the dad, right?"
So she had to convince the fathers
so that they would allow
their daughters to come.
And then, I followed up with
a question about her husband
because we saw her
husband in the movie Fadi,
who was very supportive
in how they play rolled in the beginning.
If you noticed, they
were play rolling, right?
Clocking and he was
giving her a hard time,
telling her that's what
you're gonna expect
from these fathers.
And she said at the
beginning, her husband,
he's part of the community
and these are the expectations
of the different rules
of women within that community
and taking into
consideration the war, right?
Because that changes.
I don't know how many of
us have experienced war.
It changes.
It changes your values
and not your values,
but what are your fears, right?
Where you're scared and
you wanna be protective.
So she said at the beginning,
her husband was not very
supportive of her activities
in doing things.
But she said, it's my role,
her role and the role of
woman to believe in themselves
and to have the confidence and persistence
to show that this is my passion.
I believe in this.
I want this.
It's good.
It's good for me.
It's good for my community.
And it was her persistence
and her passion that,
and the work that she did on the ground
that proved to her husband
that yes this is making her happier.
It's making her a better person.
She's actually doing things,
making a difference in the community.
So he became her staunch
supporter in many, many things.
And more than she's expressing,
we know intricately of
things that she faced
and her husband was the staunch supporter,
in supporting her,
being her back as she continued
in the different activities
in her community.
And maybe I wanna touch on this
and invite Catherine,
because we're doing
research on this right?
Trying to understand the relationships
between the mothers and the
fathers and this touches on it,
and more broadly on what is
the impact of We Love Reading
on wellbeing and happiness
and what is the mediator of that right?
Is it the agency?
Is it the motivation to lead?
What are those, the social networks?
So we've been working on this
and I'd love to hear from you.
Oh, hmm.
- That's a...
Well quickly on,
you mean on the program and
on the feelings of women.
Yeah, so I think...
I think one of the surprising things,
our research touches
many different facets,
but one of the things that
we're trying to understand
when people use the word
agency and empowerment.
And she says,
I have tried to change from within
how people understand
that process of change
and how it relates to therefore
not just your personal
psychological life satisfaction
and wellbeing,
but also how that changes
your ties with the community,
which is about networks,
and how those ties change the
opportunities that you have
to learn, work, and thrive.
I think that's the idea.
We're testing that with groups of women,
Syrian and Jordanian, who are
or not taking this program.
We Love Reading.
So it's a randomized controlled trial.
We do this to have the
best scientific evidence
of what such a program as
an exemplar program can show
with outcomes on the individual,
on society, on the learning
capacities of children.
Basically, if I were a poet,
I would say on the body,
the mind, and the brain,
and the soul.
So that is little, little pieces
to understand the value of such program.
But if I may say so too,
and I think you, Alejandra
you touched on that,
which was extraordinary.
It's a two day non-paid program
of basically of enabling people
to make changes in the
place that they are,
and so it's a very simple idea.
That's why it's can be
exported to different places.
It's a very grounded idea.
So kudos to you Rana for finding something
that is grown out of
your learning experience
and speaks to that
experience of other people.
Yeah.
- And kudos to all those women
and who are actually doing it,
but thank you for sharing that.
I wanna say...
- It's not just women who are doing it.
- Oh, yes.
- And so, that's important too.
It's young people and men.
And so Rana,
also told me one day it was
about changing mindsets.
And to change mindsets,
you have to identify the
changemakers in your communities.
And I was say, "Oh,
mindsets, changemakers."
I remember those words.
But the changemakers do not
necessarily need to be women,
they can be men.
They can be youth.
They can be anyone.
- Absolutely.
And actually touching on that,
I wanna emphasize another point
is that We Love Reading
is a program developed
within the community by the community.
I belong to that community.
I'm hlaf Syrian, half Palestinian.
I'm not somebody who came abroad and said,
"I wanna develop a program."
So I'm from the community
and I think that...
Inherent in that is the success.
It's because when you
develop for yourself,
you know better where that
challenge is coming from
and you know better to
develop a solution that works,
that's practical, that
doesn't burn you out.
And to me,
for three years as I was
developing the program,
meaning trying it myself,
trial and error,
trial and error in my neighborhood,
reading aloud to the children.
I feel it was...
People call it now human-centered design
and what Asmaa's doing
with her teenagers, right?
She's developing a program
with the girls as she moves.
Well, I liken it to evolution.
I'm a biologist, right?
So it's that natural selection.
You're trial and error, trial and error,
until you get it to the most...
You reduce it to the
most empirical formula
where with the least input
you get the maximum output,
and that's what we are reading is about.
And the reason,
I mean people talk about scaling.
I hate the word scaling, right?
Why?
Because it's implies that I have something
and I know better than you, right?
That's not what We Love Reading about.
And so what you said...
- I think you used the word diffusion.
- Diffusion or yeah,
it's like a movement.
People pick it up, right?
So that's why our logo
is changing mindsets
through reading to create a changemaker.
So we're using reading as that catalyst
for people to unlock
their inner potential,
realizing if I can do this,
what else can I do?
So it's really changing
the mindsets of people
around the world.
So every person becomes a change
maker within her community.
And so, it's changing the wording I think.
This is part of systems
change in the world.
I mean we have these paradigm shifts
that people are talking about.
How do you change the system?
So it changes by how you design,
the terms you use,
the definitions that we use to,
to make that shift in the
framework of how things are done.
So Rana is a social entrepreneur.
You can...
She has the idea
and the perseverance
and the passion to see that.
We are partnering because of research.
But I just want to say
Alejandra for instance,
you're very integral in this
because you are the person
who partners with Asmaa
and with Rana for example to show.
You show and tell the story
and that's a really remarkable
partnership I think.
And so, thank you for
making that documentary
because otherwise without you,
it doesn't have the
coverage that it deserves.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
I think that as reading is the catalyst,
film is also a catalyst for the same thing
to diffuse a message that
should be hopefully brought
to inspire many, many, many more lives.
I think I just wanted to add
regarding this conversation,
what I think is also makes
things very successful,
like change very successful,
is that both Asmaa and Rana for example,
are giving a message that they are model.
I mean they're modeling something
that they do for themselves.
So for example,
Asmaa is talking to the girls
about having a good
relationship with their father
and she is going with her father
and building that relationship.
She's talking to the
girls about dreaming big
and here she is giving conversations
and in discussions and giving the message.
She imagines herself outside of Jordan
and here she is.
Rana wanted to start a
We Love Reading program
and she was there reading to children.
So I think part of this
whole idea of creating change
is also being the change that you want
to bring to the world,
and I think that's why they're
both so, so successful.
- Everybody can be that I think...
- Everybody can be, yeah.
- It doesn't have to be
meaning we have to do it big.
We always talk, it's
about the small steps.
It's about doing the small
things and being persistent,
which is the chaos
theory in physics, right?
When a butterfly flutters its wings,
it moves the air a centimeter
but there's a huge
change in time and space
beyond what we can imagine.
And actually both me and Asmaa,
we draw this from our religion
as Muslims, both of us.
Where in Islam it tells
us be the guardian,
so take care of your community
and it says do not belittle any good deed.
Even if it's small, do it.
You're not responsible for the results.
You're responsible to try.
That's 'cause you can control trying,
and that's all you need.
And I think any person can, inside you,
you know that if you really want something
and you go and do it,
things will happen eventually.
So I wanna ask Asmaa a question
so that as we wrap up,
I dunno if anyone has
any burning questions
that you would like to ask.
Yes, please.
- There you go.
(Dominic speaking Arabic)
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
- And then, I'll translate
or you can translate.
- [Dominic] Oh yeah.
Okay, first or after?
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
- So I didn't get your name.
- [Dominic] Dominic.
- Dominic.
So Dominic asked,
what kind of literature does Asmaa read?
Because he works in, he
reads feminine literature.
I'm translating in English
when you can say it,
but it's okay.
So Asmaa responded that
she reads books by,
she mentioned a particular
author Adham Sharqawi.
So he's a...
I personally don't know him
but I'm assuming he writes a
lot of books about self-help.
She's really inspired by books
that are about self-help,
changing your personality, improving it.
Another person she reads is Wataz Mishan.
Wataz Mishan and he has a
book called (speaking Arabic).
Act foolish, a little bit?
That's foolish?
Act foolish?
We can see them here, it's okay.
Act foolish,
maybe that's the best paraphrasing.
She's also read the book by Malala
and she read my book which I'm gonna say
'cause I want people to...
The reason I'm saying it
is I wanna inspire others
to write their story, right?
It's not that my story is very special.
I'm sure there are millions
of special stories,
but we need to write them.
And I say this to
whoever's listening on Zoom
and to the young students here,
is that the most of the
literature is written
from one perspective by the global north
and we need to read the
stories of people coming
from the global south,
for lack of a better word.
I don't like global south either,
but I have to just portray
what I'm talking about,
to write our stories
because we owe it to ourselves
and we owe it to the next generation
to hear our stories and our voices.
I'm sure Asmaa's gonna write
her story, right Asmaa?
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
And then you know, Alejandra
you said something.
So in promoting for the movie,
we really prepared the whole
package, right Alejandra?
One of the slogans is we wanna
inspire a million Asmaa's
like help us have a million
Asmaa's around the world.
And I'm sure if there were,
the world would be in a much
better place than it is today.
I know Alejandra you
wanna comment on that.
- Yes.
So after we created the film,
we wanted to stop
producing films for a while
and work with Asmaa to be
able to design a strategy
that can diffuse this film
further and this message further.
And so while we were talking
with Asmaa, we asked her like,
"What would be your dream with this film
and like your highest goal?"
And so she told us
that she wanted to inspire women and girls
in vulnerable situations
like hers or others,
other situations,
to be able to dream and
to continue their lives
whatever situation or
adversity they may be facing.
And so that became our primary goal,
and we decided to partner
with more organizations around the world
that have the means to be able
to reach our target audience,
and through the film,
use the film as a tool
to be able to inspire, educate,
and empower more women and girls.
We also suggest to any
partner organization
that wants to use the
film to empower more girls
to talk about their empowerment programs.
Because as Rana said,
we didn't really mention
We Love Reading in the film
because it's Asmaa's story
and Asmaa's story can inspire more people.
If it takes another empowerment program
to be that little push
that Rana is talking about,
then so be it if that
will help and support
and enable more Asmaa's in the world.
So that's our impact
campaign with this film
and it's moving along smoothly so far.
- Alright, so as we end,
I wanna ask if Asmaa wants
to share a final word.
(Rana speaking Arabic)
(Asmaa speaking Arabic)
- So Asmaa was saying for the girl,
I asked her about the girls
in the picture in the end
when they were all together,
like where does she
see them in the future?
And she says,
I tell them that if they believe something
then it can happen if
they believe in it enough.
And that if in order to achieve it,
they have to believe
and they have to work hard
enough for it and it will happen.
And that she still is in
touch with these girls
and she tells them,
I don't have to be beside you.
You need to learn to
depend on your own selves.
Her last piece of advice,
she's saying amongst you,
either fathers and mothers
now or will be in the future,
that listen to your girls.
Believe in them,
believe in their dreams and their ideas.
Because even if they appear
to be simple or silly,
they are important to them, to the girls.
So listen to them, support them
because they are the future.
And she says,
these girls, their dreams will come true.
Her daughter Tamara always dreamed
of being in a forest among,
a lot of trees.
And you saw Zataari right?
There were no trees
and now she's in France
where there's a lot of trees.
So her dream has come true in that sense
and she thanks everybody as well.
So over to you.
- So we need to close.
I want to thank you all
for being with us today.
I want to thank Rana for
being with us in person.
I want to thank Asmaa
for coming from Paris.
I want to thank Alejandra
for coming from Barcelona,
I believe,
and I want to thank you for being with us.
Also, of course,
I want to thank the three
programs that made this possible:
the Program on Refugees,
Forced Displacement,
and Humanitarian
Responses at the MacMillan,
the Program on Conflict,
Resilience, and Health
at the MacMillan Center of Yale
and the Program on Global Health Studies.
So thank you very much and I
hope your journey continues.
- Thank you.
(everyone applauding)